vidéo,
certains d'entre nous n'ont pas de métier,
donc si nous faisons cela,
nous voyons le pouvoir maintenant, essentiellement
[musique],
nous voyons un grand nombre de
personnes non autorisées comme les sans-abri et les
vagabonds. Ce que je peux dire, c'est qu'ils
font un travail louable.  en
aidant les membres du public, mais un
léger défi est que si un
accident peut se produire alors qu'ils
contrôlent la circulation, malheureusement, la
ville de Johannesburg ne sera pas responsable
des dommages ou blessures survenus. La
tâche étrangère est de réduire considérablement la
gravité du délestage.  dans les mois à venir
et, à terme, mettre un terme aux délestages